hi there this is uh steve kaufman here
uh i want to talk a little bit more
about the subject of correction in
language learning it seems to have
generated a lot of interest
you'll notice that i have a different
background
i've been banished upstairs to the attic
here
um when i first started doing these
videos i was up here
i thought i'd call my video corner the
tower because i was at that time reading
about montana who had a tower there in
southern france where he
philosophized and read and
and uh i also vaguely remember that um
who was it now machiavelli
uh at one point was banished and uh he
he
was imprisoned or something and then in
the evenings he would
dress up nicely and read and communicate
with uh the writers of classical times
whatever so there's something about
being in this little tower i'm
surrounded by books i'm not going to
show you all the books in this little
room
and so i'm back up here because i sat in
there with my wife and she found that i
was too messy and so we were sharing
this one little office and she kicked me
out
so i'm up here now now
with regard to corrections
um
obviously i sometimes say things
to stimulate discussion and to get
people out of certain established
patterns
and the main reason why i say we
shouldn't correct
is is the main reason that i've designed
linked the way i have and and sort of
the base of my beliefs in language
learning and that is
we have to try to make the learner
independent
uh the the more independent the learner
is
the more and the sooner and the more
quickly and the better the learner will
learn
so if the learner is expecting the
teacher to correct all his or her
mistakes
then it's going to take longer to learn
uh most of the mistakes we discover them
on our own
now that is not to say that it doesn't
occasionally help to get a mistake
pointed out and let's be honest you know
i can come across as a bit of an
ideologue myself
but when i'm tutoring someone in english
here at link i do correct if it's a one
on one and sometimes even in a group
it's hard to avoid it
if a person keeps making keeps on making
the same mistake
so we inevitably do correct to some
extent
i try not to correct
too much
and there's different kinds of mistakes
if the person uses a word that doesn't
mean what they think it does then i'm
likely to stop them and say no that's
not how we use that word in fact it's
this other word or if they use an
expression like
very often hear people say how to say
how to say
and i say well no no in terms of filler
words in english we don't say how to say
how to say we say you know i mean well
what i mean to say is so i would
recommend that they get themselves an
english filler expression rather than
something that is obviously not native
and those kinds of things are easy
to explain and relatively easy to
remember
however when it comes to things like
grammar if someone points out to me that
i have my case wrong in russian
it has no impact on me whatsoever
i must admit also if i am struggling for
a word in russian and the
my tutor gives me the word i won't
remember it
however
i will remember if i read it or i have a
better chance to remember if i read it
and that's why i have said i like
written
um
you know lists of errors especially in
today's computer age where i can import
them and save them and
flash card them if i want and so forth
um
correcting people's pronunciation i have
found to be relatively useless
in discussions i sometimes do it but
they go right back
to pronouncing things the way they like
because that's how their brain is
configured and it takes a long time to
change one's pronunciation and that's
where i recommend a lot of repetitive
listening to a limited amount of content
and even to content which focuses on
those sounds
that people have trouble with
but correcting their pronunciation in a
discussion i found to be relatively
useless
there were other comments i think was
vera who said that stronger learners
can benefit more from correction and i
think that's true if you've got a strong
base then if you are saying
just a few things wrong then it's easier
to deal with although i must say that i
have people that i deal with
in business
who speak english well well enough to do
business whether they're japanese or
german or french or swedish or whatever
and
i mean i would never correct their
english if we're having a business
discussion never
i mean they have every right to be
offended
now with some people that i know very
well like there's a gentleman i know in
sweden
and he speaks flawless english almost
sounds like an english country gentleman
but he has his swedish expressions like
instead of saying there are
many people
in the restaurant he will say it is many
people in the restaurant because that's
how it's said in swedish and no matter
how often i remind him of that he cannot
change so i'm just saying correction
yeah maybe i think it works
for in some cases it can help you become
aware of where your gaps are i like it
in writing it's better for more advanced
learners a beginner learner i mean you
would be correcting every second word
in fact i recommend that beginner
learners don't do very much talking at
all so that they can accumulate more
words and phrases you can't make a
mistake while you're listening and
reading you only make a mistake when you
start
producing the language
so now i also had a look at moses
my friend moses he did a video response
on this whole subject
and
i think he he agrees with me and i agree
with him too that that correction can
sometimes help and so you get people
saying well correction helped me and
sometimes it does
i think where moses and i agree is that
you wouldn't do it without the
permission
of the person involved
and uh i know if i'm trying to
communicate and and when i'm
communicating what's important to me is
what i want to say
because i think i'm having a meaningful
conversation and if the other person is
is interrupting me to correct me i'm not
that fond of that but other people may
be
um
one thing i should say about moses i do
recommend that you watch his videos
and what i like about his videos and i
don't always be
praising moses and then he praises me
and it looks like we've got a mutual
uh you know support society going here
but
of the people that do videos about
language
i think he is the best teacher he may
not be the best linguist i have no idea
i haven't heard him in all his different
languages
there are people who speak more
languages or who appear to speak them
better but he's a very good teacher and
that's why i would recommend you you
follow his
videos
if you're interested in language
learning or
make contact with him and the reason i
think he's a good teacher is because he
takes his time
he is patient
he is i would even use the word kindly
and the best teachers i had were
teachers who were kindly who were
genuinely interested in me
uh i think i am too impatient to be a
good teacher i think a good teacher has
to go very slowly because
the problem is
that a teacher knows something that the
student doesn't know
and so it's very easy to go charging
ahead because you're very familiar with
something
and so
and we do have to have said this about
language learning itself you almost have
to know the language before you can
study it and that's why i'm against
grammar until you're very familiar with
it you can't study the rules the rules
don't make sense
well the same is true of language
learning and i think i jump too quickly
at times i have my experience of
language learning and so based on that i
say you learn languages this way and
that way
and moses i think is closer to his
students
more in tune with where they are gives
it to them and then repeats it in a very
kindly way and and in a very encouraging
way
uh and so he i think is probably more
likely to turn on the student make them
independent
make them good language learners
which is what what he of course proposes
to do
with his videos i've never been to one
of his classes let me see if i made any
other notes here yeah one last thing uh
you know
and and both moses and i encourage
people to just enjoy themselves and
there's no right way or wrong way you
can either
uh you know i'm gonna run out of time
but the whole thing is languages are
about having fun it's not like we're
training engineers or
neurosurgeons you make a mistake it
doesn't really matter explore the
languages however you want do many or do
few
do it as thoroughly as you want or as
superficially as you want just enjoy
yourself here we go bye for now